Okej, så har jag bort en bort bort, för att någon var understånden om hur agens är en väst.
Jag inte minns med agens, jag vill bilda dem.
Så i en order att göra AI, inte stupit, så måste du röra det till den här länningen.
Du kan få ut den här länningen, få ut den här länningen, och få ut den här länningen.
Detta är att de har bort framtiden att göra det.
Länkän, den anthropikagent SDK, som antakernal.
All of those are different ways to rönt den här problemen.
Fyltrees
och du har tasks inside that workflow.
Det också kan ha multiple workflows.
De är just folders, okej?
inside of that workflow,
task 1,
har instructions,
vilket är proms,
tools,
och data.
Same for task 2,
och du kan ha subtasks
med Its Own Instructions tools och data.
En single coding agent
från någon av de stora gejs
kan ha all of the instructions
och processas in there
och också ha MCP-servers
vilket kan ha outside data
vilket kan ha subagents
vilket kan ha all others tasks
och ha nya strukturer
inside of your folder.
All of that,
without you having to code
in Python
or C-sharp,
like semantic kernel requires.
Best part is
this isn't going to get replaced
by an update.
If they make a feature,
one of the bigger people
to do some of this,
guess what?
You just condense that into a tool.
If they
condense your workflow
into a feature update,
guess what?
It's now a subtask
or a tool.
You are operating
on the wrong abstraction layer
if you think AI is moving too fast.